hi everybody just before we jump into
the video today i do want to say that
i've got a brand new channel it's called
geographics which is a geography channel
we look at really interesting places all
around the world
you can find that channel linked below
if you like it please do consider
subscribing
and over to today's video he's perhaps
the greatest
ever humanitarian oscar schindler was a
german industrialist who saved the lives
of over a thousand jews during the
holocaust
the subject of a hit 1982 book and a
1993 steven spielberg film that hit even
bigger
oscar schindler today is a household
name you probably think you already know
him how he started out as a cynical
businessman before finding redemption
how he courted the nazi leadership to
save jewish lives even how his humanity
was finally stirred by the sight of one
red-coated girl dying in the krakow
ghetto but
what if we told you there was far more
to oscar schindler than you thought
what if we told you that he wasn't just
a cynical businessman but a war
profiteer
a nazi spy and a traitor who was nearly
executed for collaborating in the video
today we're going to take you inside the
life of oscar schindler and explore how
a one-time nazi stooge succeeded in
finding his humanity
and in doing so saving the world
[Music]
the story of oscar schindler technically
begins on april 28 in 1908 when he was
born in the pretty town
of zwitau we say technically because
there's not really much to say about
those early days
schindler was born into a middle-class
german family he had a younger sister
and he went to school
exciting stuff from a purely narrative
point of view the story of oscar
schindler can
actually be said to start nearly 11
years later on october 29
1918. that's the date the schindler
family's comfortable middle class world
exploded now you see the schindlers were
ethnic germans but they didn't live in
germany they lived in the
austro-hungarian empire specifically
in a region known as the sudetenland
above them lay germany proper
somewhere below them lay austria itself
but between the schindlers and austria
lay a land that was very ungerman a land
that had spent centuries chafing under
austrian rule
until it was completely sick of germans
that land was about to declare itself
the brand new country of czechoslovakia
on that day october 29 1918 just as
world war one was drawing to an end
the czechs and slovaks deposed the
austrians and announced a new slavic
republic
like all sudate and germans the
schindlers took one look at the emerging
czechoslovak state and said
yeah we'd rather be the germany to which
the czechs replied
well they didn't actually say anything
they just picked up their guns and
started shooting
the pro-german riots that broke out
across the sudetenland
only ended when czech authorities in
kadan emptied a machine gun into a crowd
killing 25. in the context of the time
the kodan massacre it wasn't
particularly egregious
along the ethnic fault line of the old
austro-hungarian empire polls were
killing czechs who were killing germans
who were killing poles
and so on but it did provoke a shock to
any sudate and germans tempted to buy
into the whole
czechoslovakia thing like all their
neighbors the schindlers would remember
kadan
that september the treaty of san jamal
made the czech takeover official
while this was pretty sucky news for the
sedate and germans we need to be clear
that this
wasn't the apocalypse as part of
czechoslovakia sedate and germans were
allowed to continue speaking german they
could
attend german language schools keep
their businesses and so on an evil
occupying force the czechoslovaks
were not but they were resented the new
czechoslovakia was 50
czech 23 percent german 16 slovak
plus a handful of jews ukrainians and
hungarians
but while the slovaks got their own
federal parliament the more numerous
sudate and germans were
stuck as bit players in the czech system
it wasn't terrible in other words
some families such as the schindlers
even thrived under the new regime
but it was a cause of discontent you
could imagine it as
the world's slowest time bomb by
ignoring the sudate and german's wishes
the
czechs had just accidentally pressed the
on button that su date and time bomb
might not explode for decades but when
it did it was going to blow
the whole of europe to pieces
[Music]
alright so that's the world that oscar
schindler inhabited now what about the
man himself
well there's a bit of a problem
schindler wasn't exactly a man so much
as he was a boy he was a boy who
enjoyed nothing more than goofing off
and chasing pretty girls
and it was going to be a long time
before that boy grew up in 1924
schindler was dismissed from school for
falsifying his report card rather than
try to continue his education he instead
moved to
a series of odd jobs around zwittal the
actual content of these jobs
doesn't matter they were really just a
front for the tall and charming
schindler to
prowl around seducing as many girls as
he could
before he was even 20 schindler had a
reputation as a guy who loved ladies
loved cars and
hated personal responsibility still even
the biggest casanova will eventually
settle down and
for schindler that settling came in
1928.
in late january that year schindler
traveled to alt molitine for his work as
a salesman while at the house of a
client he happened to bump into their
daughter
from the moment he met emily palzol
schindler was knocked for six
that's a cricket metaphor for all you
americans you might say
he was knocked for a home run or
something equally ludicrous
for her part emily was knocked for a
winning basket too the pair began an
intense courtship that climaxed with
them marrying just six weeks later
this happened on march the 6th 1928 as a
gift for the married couple emily's
father gave them a hundred thousand
czech crowns perhaps hoping they'd
buy a small house or something instead
schindler blew it on a luxury car and
the couple moved in with schindler's
parents
for emily the experience was a rude
awakening although he claimed to
genuinely love her schindler treated his
new wife
less like a lifelong companion and more
like someone to come home to when he
couldn't find a better offer it was
probably a relief when schindler was
conscripted into the czechoslovak army
for 18 months of service
and speaking of czechoslovakia things
seemed to be going
kind of alright in 1928 the country had
existed for 10 years now and the sudeten
germans initial resistance had
settled down into a kind of grumbling
that was probably helped by the fact
that the czechoslovak economy was
booming while
germany was a weimar basket case but
those resentments they were still
there and it would only take one sharp
outside
shock to crack them wide open that shock
came on october 29 1929 that day wall
street came
crashing down under the weight of a
billion broken dreams
the global economy had ground to a halt
hunger
misery and fear bit for oscar schindler
this meant being discharged from the
army just in time to see his old company
file for bankruptcy
used to a lavish lifestyle schindler
first tried moving to berlin then he
tried opening a poultry farm but
nothing worked finally he took over his
father's business in zwatau only to
watch it too go bankrupt it was a grim
and desperate time for the schindlers
for most of the world but not for
everyone across the czechoslovak border
a funny little man with a charlie
chaplin mustache was about to find that
the great depression had created a
willing audience for his message of
white
nationalism and anti-elitism his name
was
adolf hitler and he was about to force
every sudatan german
to make a terrible choice
the suddenness of hitler's rise to power
is the sort of career the word meteoric
is reserved for in the 1928 jones
election the nazis won a paltry 2.5
percent of the votes the
sort of number even the u.s libertarian
party would have a good laugh at
by the july 1932 election though they
were the biggest party with nearly 40
percent of the vote
less than a year later they'd seized
power back in the sudetenland unemployed
and impoverished germans watched the
rise of the nazis with
ill-disguised envy in 1933 a sudatan
german gymnastics coach named conrad
haneline decided to try and capture some
of that fascist magic by
founding his own party the sudeytin
deutsche heimet front
a nazi organization in all but name the
heimat front had
one goal to split the sudetenland off
from czechoslovakia
and unite with hitler's germany it was a
goal most of the sudan germans were
really more than on board with
in may of 1935 the czechoslovak
elections returned to 44 seats for
henline's wannabe nazis a
single seat less than the largest party
that same year
oscar schindler officially joined the
heimet front many biographers of
schindler go to great lengths to explain
that he was a pure opportunist and that
he merely joined for financial
opportunities given what we know about
his later life and his good deeds it's
tempting to agree but there's no
escaping the fact that history
is rarely black and white and had you
glanced at oscar schindler's cv in 1936
you would have had a hard time believing
that he was anything but a nazi
that's the year schindler joined the
abbver the german intelligence agency
under the app there schindler turned spy
for nazi germany he began collecting
information
before long he was working on
clandestine activities that could
only have pointed in one direction the
nazis they were preparing for an
invasion of czechoslovakia
schindler would later say that he only
took this work for the money because he
was badly in debt and he was addicted to
drink
there's also no doubt that the work of
schindler and other sudan german spies
like him helped hitler get
exactly what he wanted in february of
1938 hitler felt confident enough to
demand self-determination for all
sudatan germans
a month later he annexed austria on
april the 24th conrad henlein the
nazi gymnast who set up the heimet front
he demanded full
autonomy for the sudetenland within
czechoslovakia
the jets told him to take a hike but
henlein was
merely playing for time on the ground
schindler and his other spies
fanned out working overtime to prepare
for the nazi invasion but ask a
schindler
he wouldn't be around to see it on july
18 1938 check authorities arrested
schindler as a spy he was found guilty
and he was sentenced to hang as a
traitor he was saved of all people
by adolf hitler on september 28th
britain france
germany and italy all met in munich to
hammer out an agreement that would stop
the sudeten crisis from triggering world
war ii the deal they reached was to just
give
everything to hitler on october 1st the
sedating land was handed over to germany
at the time schindler was on death row
we've seen a couple of sources claim
that he was only
days or perhaps even hours away from
being executed when the nazis marched in
as part of the munich agreement
schindler was freed the traitor had
escaped death by
the skin of his teeth one month later
schindler was a citizen of germany
living inside the new sedation land
perhaps to celebrate
he joined the nazi party
if you only know oscar schindler from
schindler's list you might be wondering
what is life story is gonna start
sounding less like one of our depressing
videos about nazi criminals and
more like one of those uplifting videos
that you know
aren't about nazi criminals the trouble
is schindler is a morally complex guy
and the picture is about to become even
murkier in november of 1938 the ad there
ordered schindler and emily to ostrava
a grimy industrial city on the polish
border for schindler this meant numerous
business trips into poland gathering
intelligence
yet it also meant doing things that
don't neatly fit in with the narrative
of
schindler being a spy for instance it
was in ostrava that schindler started
bribing local nazi officials acting
less like a true believer and more like
a guy looking to secure
favorable treatment it was in ostrava
that chindler began dabbling in the
black market
next summer just a few short months
after hitler invaded czechoslovakia
schindler landed a juicy contract to
supply stolen polish army uniforms to a
nazi agent
not long after men dressed as polish
soldiers launched surprise attacks on
german buildings in the aftermath of
this
hitler declared war on poland the
invasion of poland lasted barely a month
on september 1st 1939 the first tanks
rolled in by october the 6th
the last polish units had surrendered by
then some 60 000 poles had been killed
from oscar schindler's perspective
though the occupation of poland was
simply
a whole new market opening up barely had
the last fires of resistance been put
out then schindler was on a train to
krakow
eager to help himself to the spolls of
war in the grand red brick city he took
over a vast apartment that had once
belonged to a wealthy jewish family
he moved into the black market and began
chasing shady dealings
pretty soon after that he was making a
killing while emily was laid up back
home with a debilitating illness
schindler began living the high life
whining and
dining local nazi leaders and acting
like a total playboy
it's at this point that the movie
schindler's list opens with
schindler establishing connections on
the krakow business scene not giving the
smallest dam about the suffering going
on around him
but if crackout life was the high
watermark for schindler the
uncaring money obsessed collaborator it
was also something
else it was in krakow that schindler
would finally discover
his own humanity
on november 13th 1939 schindler took
over a krakow enamel factory that had
once been owned by jewish businessmen
barely had the doors opened in january
of 1940 then schindler had used his new
nazi contacts to land himself a fat
contract supplying the army with
kitchenware he'd also done something
very interesting he'd rehired one of the
jews who used to work on the factory
as his manager a guy called abraham
bankia still
bankia was a rarity in schindler's
faction at first by april 1940
schindler's staff had grown to several
hundred but only seven of them were
jewish the remaining jews in krakow were
subject to some strict laws among
restrictions on their clothing and
movements the jews also had their wages
set by the state at
a pitifully low amount as schindler's
factory business grew
abraham bankia came up with an idea an
idea
was to hire more jews thanks to the
labor laws it would be much cheaper than
hiring polls thereby
saving schindler a pile of money that
word money
it was the key as desirables presumably
transformed into gigantic dollar signs
schindler agreed to expand his jewish
workforce it was a decision
that would alter the fates of hundreds
of people by spring of 1941 most of
krakow's jews were living in a ghetto
while
schindler continued his party lifestyle
it was against this backdrop that the ss
announced that jews could no longer earn
wages
employers such as schindler would have
to pay jewish wages
instead to the ss there was a minor
legal tweak just another in a long list
of
injustice and oppression it also changed
everything suddenly the ability of
schindler's jewish workers to survive
was
contingent upon him he could choose to
work until they dropped then
ask the ss for replacements or he could
start feeding them out of his own money
not long after schindler arranged for
his black market context to
start supplying him extra rations of
food come january 1942 schindler's
factory had been
converted from somewhere producing
enamel to somewhere producing armaments
for the german war effort
its employees they changed too from a
mere seven
originally schindler was now employing
hundreds of jews
[Music]
if the last couple of years it allowed
schindler to be ambivalent about the
nazis to
avoid taking anyone's side 1942 would be
the year that everyone had to choose
on february the 15th of that year the
first jews earmarked for extermination
arrived in auschwitz
and were immediately gassed barely a
month later on march the 17th the
belzeck extermination camp opened as
well
although auschwitz was closer it was to
belzek that the nazis initially herded
krakow's jews
it wasn't quite a mass slaughter yet
those who worked in factories like
schindler's were saved from deportation
but things they would quickly get
much much worse that june 1942 the
placer work camp opened four kilometers
outside of krakow atop the remains of
two jewish cemeteries
many of the jews from schindler's employ
were relocated there and forced to march
to and from the factory
every morning and every evening it was a
grueling existence and a precarious one
with the ss looking after the camp any
jew who stepped out of line could be
murdered
no matter who they worked for for his
part schindler did what he could to make
factory life comfortable for his workers
but
he had no control of what happened in
plaza and that was about to become a
major problem
as a summer in hell gave way to a winter
of misery
an intellectual young man from a wealthy
austrian publishing family was
dispatched to plaza
to take over the camp his name was ammon
gert
of all the nazis we've encountered in
today's story he was by far the worst
known for being played by ralph fiennes
in schindler's list the real gert was
worse than his fictional counterpart as
in the film he used jews in plaza as
target practice
he trained dogs to maul jews to death on
command
he hated the idea that any jew should
have the faintest
taste of freedom so what did oscar
schindler do when he was faced with this
particular monster well he set about
becoming his best friend
over the next few weeks schindler
showered gert and cognac find cigars and
cups of meat only available on the black
market he took the sadist to parties
charmed him with his witty conversation
and did everything he could to make sure
that gerd thought he was a brown noser
of the highest order it was only when
gert announced in march that the krakow
ghetto was to be liquidated and all jews
relocated inside platill
that schindler struck as ss soldiers
wreaked havoc in the ghetto and the
chimneys of belzette's pumped human ash
into the sky
schindler deployed a charm offensive as
deadly as any weapon he flat had got
cajoled him bribed him
offered to let him in on his black
market racket before long he'd
run an incredible promise out of this
creature in human skin
gurt had agreed to let schindler
relocate his factory inside plaza
what's more schindler would have
complete autonomy in the subcamp
to do whatever he wanted for schindler
that meant the autonomy
to be a decent human being the plateau
jews who were relocated to schindler's
subcamp were given adequate food their
living conditions were humane
they were free from violence schindler
even banned the ss from entering
indeed the aryan supermen were stuck
stewing in towers watching over
schindler's jews but
unable to harm them it was the sort of
thing only a man
close to the commandant gert could have
gotten away with
and it's here that we get to the
greatest paradox of oscar schindler had
he been a good man from the start
schindler would have never been in a
position where he could have saved so
many lives the nazis would have
confiscated everything he owned and
just run him out of town but because he
started out spying against the czechs
because he really was a venal money
grubbing a moral
cynic at first he was able to have the
trust of committed nazis like gurt
when he needed it most and now with
placia running and auschwitz devouring
humans and
turning the skies of a crack out black
with burning flesh
schindler needed that trust
[Music]
in august 1944 among gert received a
disturbing order
the soviet army was rolling towards
poland and the reich was in retreat
placial was about to be decommissioned
and all of its inhabitants were going to
be sent to auschwitz when oscar
schindler heard the news he
went into panic mode despite what they
later said in trials and
to themselves as they were trying to get
to sleep at night everyone
in plattel knew by then what auschwitz
was with time running out schindler
began loudly petitioning to have his
factory relocated to brunelitz near his
hometown he was doing
essential work he thundered the war
effort would fail without him hadn't he
always been good to gert
finally gert agreed to authorize
schindler's transfer
and what about my workers schindler
asked draw up a list
god told him any you can prove you need
i'll let you take with you
and so it was that schindler's real life
list came to be written
however it wouldn't actually be
schindler who wrote it in the movie
schindler and his accountant sit down to
write the list themselves
agonizing over every name in reality
schindler had to give the job to a man
named
marcel goldberg why well because in
september of 1944
among gert was arrested by the ss for
bribery and black marketeering he
spilled the beans on his co-criminals
and schindler was arrested too
that october while schindler sat in jail
marcel goldberg prepared the list
actually there were up to nine versions
or subtly different and goldberg's
involvement it was controversial
some claim he focused on saving the
lives of his friends over those of
schindler's workers
but others paint a picture of goldberg
as being a caring man
one young survivor recalls begging
goldberg to let her and her mother onto
the list
goldberg immediately sat down and added
their names when the list was finally
submitted the ss demanded to inspect the
workers
the men were all processed and sent to
brunettes the women however
they were accidentally sent to auschwitz
from inside his jail
schindler frantically arranged
representative to go to the death camp
and save those women from extermination
it was a close run thing but it worked
the women they were returned alive
not long after schindler's contacts got
him released from jail finally after two
months
of panic schindler and the workers it
saved arrived in brunettes
between the bribes he paid the gifts he
showered on those in power and the cost
of the move he shouldered
schindler had by now spent nearly his
entire fortune
when they arrived he blew the last of it
on trucks full of wool leather shoes and
clothing materials for his workers
schindler and his jews they then settled
in to
wait out the war-making armaments that
were designed to fail
doing their own tiny bit to hinder the
nazi war effort amazingly no one stopped
them no angry ss officers
ever even turned up to arrest schindler
when the third reich finally collapsed
on may
8 1945 schindler had managed to shield
1098 jews from the holocaust
now all he had to do was survive its
aftermath
[Music]
on may 9 1945 oscar schindler gathered
his employees at his factory for one
final goodbye he made a short speech
saying how proud he was to have helped
save so many jewish lives
then he emily and a handful of his
workers they fled the sudetenland
barely ahead of the advancing soviet
army his fortune gone schindler would
spend the rest of his life
in financial misery at first he and
emily tried settling down in west
germany before deciding the u.s might be
a better bet
unfortunately his nazi party membership
automatically excluded him from america
so
schindler instead submitted an expenses
claim for one million dollars to the
allies
asking to be paid back for the money
that it spent saving jews in the war
after a long deliberation they sent him
fifteen thousand dollars and told him to
be happy
schindler spent this money on a ticket
to argentina it could have been the
start of a new life but while
actual nazi war criminals were able to
start afresh in argentina
and lead peaceful lives schindler seemed
destined to failure by 1957 he was
forced to declare bankruptcy the next
year he abandoned emily and
caught a boat back to west germany there
he sank into a mire of poverty
and that's really it unfortunately
schindler never again enjoyed the high
life
never again got to be a playboy never
again stood
at the center of history but he wasn't
totally forgotten
for the rest of his life schindler
regularly received donations
not a huge amount just enough to keep
him going keep him safe
keep him alive as you probably guessed
those donations came from the 1098 jews
had saved
as a token of their thanks known as the
schlinder juden they supported him until
the very end
that end came on october 9 1974.
by then schindler had lived long enough
to see his name added to the avenue of
the righteous in israel a place reserved
for those gentiles who
risked their lives to save jews during
the holocaust and it was back to israel
that schindler returned in death
his body was buried in the catholic
cemetery on mount zion today is
estimated there are over 8
500 people alive because of schindler
descendants of the jews he saved but
there are better reasons to remember
schindler than
just for saving lives the famous quote
goes that the only thing necessary for
the triumph of evil
is for good men to do nothing certainly
plenty of good men
alive during the holocaust were content
not to do anything
but the life of oscar schindler shows
that sometimes the opposite can happen
sometimes a man who appears to be
immoral who appears to be just another
uncaring bystander
can shake themselves out of their stupor
and do a good deed
that will change the world the quote
everyone remembers from schindler's list
is the one that goes
he who saves one life saves the entire
world
in choosing to be a good man when the
downtrodden needed him most
schindler saved the world a thousand
times over